et allons plus loin dans l'entretien
avec nous ce soir isabelle mais jean
bienvenu merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation je le disais vous êtes
économiste professeur à l'école
polytechnique lauréate du prix meilleur
jeune économiste 2020 on le voit en ce
chef d'entreprise à relocaliser une
partie de son activité ça a marché
on n'entend plus que ça depuis la fin de
cette crise pas du tout la faim depuis
le début de cette crise qu'ovide
relocalisons relocalisons relocalisons à
tort selon vous à tort je sais pas
disons que moi j'ai l'impression qu'on
entend beaucoup ça sur plein de sujets
différents
sans beaucoup de précision sur ce qu'on
veut relocaliser donc voila moi même
discours c'est un peu de dire on
relocalise pas la même chose selon
différents objectifs qu'on veut
atteindre donc c'est très important de
bien préciser quels sont les objectifs
visés et après de spécifier quels sont
les types d'activités qu'on veut
localiser ou relocalisés selon le cas et
puis aussi considérer quelles sont les
outils multiples un qu'on peut mobiliser
et dans ce cas là à essayer de réfléchir
au meilleur mix de politique pour
atteindre un objectif donné mais encore
une fois je pense que c'est très
important de bien spécifier l'objectif
parce que justement dans les débats on a
parlé d'objectifs très nombreux et qui
sont pas du tout compatible disons les
uns avec les autres
on entrera dans le détail de ce qu'il
faut ou pas relocalisé ou localiser
puisque c'est effectivement votre
discours on y viendra dans un instant
mais d'abord pendant des décennies la
logique c'était quand même si je peux
fabriquer ailleurs moins cher je le fais
maintenant la petite musique c'est donc
plutôt je relocalise
et puis on verra pour les coûts est ce
que vous craignez qu'on tombe dans
l'extrême inverse qui est une forme de
d'idéologie de la relocalisation
non je pense qu'il faut déjà qu'ils
aient un effet massif pour que pour
qu'on arrive à ces extrêmes là et je
pense pas qu'on va arriver enfin
un changement complet de modèle j'ai pas
l'impression que ce soit ça dont on
parle donc ici on parle de choses qui
sont quand même assez ciblées on reste
un pays dans un marché unique donc le
commerce reste quand même une partie
importante de notre fonctionnement et
qui nous apporte des bénéfices
importants et je pense pas qu'ils aient
des questions de revenir sur sur sa donc
non je pense pas qu'il ya un risque très
important que vous l'avez dit un tout
petit peu tout à l'heure vous avez
prononcé le mot localiser localisation
donc il ya une différence évidemment
être relocalisés localiser ce que
pouvaient nous l'expliqué cette
différence bat dans la notion de
relocalisation il ya une idée que ce
qu'il s'agisse d'activités qui étaient
avant produite en france qui ont été
déplacés donc souvent dans des pays qui
ont des coûts du travail moins élevés et
qu'on essaierait de rapatrier en france
donc il ya cette idée vraiment de sueur
sur le type d'activités dont on parle la
production de chaussettes le textile
donc le textile chez un bon exemple
c'est une industrie qui a été très
fortement délocaliser ont produit très
peu de textile en france aujourd'hui on
produit sur des niches très particulière
plutôt le luxe et ses savoir-faire voilà
sur des savoir-faire de niche mais le
gros du textile aujourd'hui et produits
dans des pays émergents un coût du
travail beaucoup plus fait parce que
c'est un une industrie qui est très
intensive en travail donc voilà donc si
on veut re localiser ce type d'industrie
c'est très différent disons plutôt de
que de localiser des activités c'est à
dire d'essayer plus largement
d'augmenter l'attractivité de la france
de prod2 créer de l'emploi et de
l'activité sur des industries
lesquels par exemple justement dans quel
type de secteur pourrions nous localiser
donc là là le si on commence à parler en
termes d'avantagés comparatifs c'est à
dire la notion qu'on a du commerce
international elle repose beaucoup sur
cette notion que les pays ne savent pas
faire aussi bien les mêmes choses ça
c'est vrai donc certains pays ont plutôt
un avantage comparatif sur des biens
très intensif en travail parce que le
coût du travail est faible d'autres pays
ont plutôt un avantage comparatif sur
des productions qui sont plus intensives
en capital en technologie on travaille
qualifier et donc de ce point de vue là
la france considère c'est plutôt un pays
qui est un avantage comparatif sur des
activités à fort contenu en technologie
on travaille qualifier et donc c'est
plus facile disons de créer des
activités dans ces domaines là donc
voilà les activités qui sont très
intensive en en technologie ont ça va
être mon tout ce qui a hero nautique le
matériel de transport mais il ya aussi
la chimie la pharmacie
ce genre d'activité où il ya un contenu
en technologie en innovation et en
travail qualifiées qui est plus
important que dans d'autres secteurs où
l'avant le coût va beaucoup dépendre
finalement de facteurs liés notamment
que du travail on pourrait localisé par
exemple des activités qui nous pousse
vers la transition écologique on aurait
ce ses capacités là en france
moi je pense personnellement que c'est
quelque chose sur lequel il faut miser
parce que finalement on voit bien la
transition écologique
elle nécessite des ruptures
technologiques donc c'est des activités
qui par définition n'existe pas beaucoup
aujourd'hui et qui sont destinés à
exister beaucoup plus dans le futur en
tout cas on l'espère il se trouve que
sur ces questions là en europe on a
plutôt un avantage parce qu on a eu un
peu plus tôt d'autres pays une politique
très volontariste transition écologique
donc il ya des incitations fortes qui
sont faites des dépenses importantes
dans la technologie dans la recherche et
développement sur des technologies
de rupture écologique et donc de ce
point de vue là il ya quand même une
fenêtre de tir qui consiste à dire un
peu faisons des investissements massifs
qui vont nous permettre nous de réduire
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
réduire notre empreinte carbone en
misant aussi sur le fait que dans le
futur d'autres pays vont se joindre
on espère quand même que rapidement ça
va être un mouvement beaucoup plus
important et donc la vence européenne va
se réduire très rapidement et danse à ce
moment là ce sera important du point de
vue du pur avantages comparatifs
finalement d'avoir déjà développé des
compétences donc moi je pense que c'est
là dedans les investissements qui
peuvent être rentables
évidemment pour des objectifs premiers
qui sont la transition écologique mais
aussi qu'ils peuvent constituer dans le
futur aussi une source d' avantage
comparatif pour des entreprises qui
auront très tôt finalement investi dans
des technologies qui aujourd'hui sont
peu rentables mais qui le deviendront
dans le futur ça pourrait même
rééquilibrer les rapports de force dans
les échanges commerciaux c'est à dire
que finalement deviendraient des
puissants dans un certain domaine et qui
nous donnerait un avantage commercial
quand on dit on ne sait pas trop de
clients pas mais l'europe reste une
puissance commerciale très importante
donc on a déjà des avantages comparatifs
très fort sur certains domaines
oui on a beaucoup parlé du secteur
pharmaceutique pendant la crise c'est un
secteur où il ya un avantage comparatif
historique très très forts de l'europe
les états unis le roi l'europe
produisent une grande
quantité de produits pharmaceutiques etc
donc on a fait tous flageller en
attendant que ça a beaucoup exagéré et
l'europe est une très grosse puissance
commerciale la finition le dire dans
l'europe et pas dans une position de
compétitivité très bonne donc si on
commence à se comparer à l'intérieur de
l'europe sûr que là la comparaison n'est
pas toujours aussi flatteuse mais voilà
les avantages comparatifs de l'europe
il existe aujourd'hui il va évoluer
parce que c'est quelque chose qui évolué
au cours du temps et c'est vrai en chine
comme c'est vrai en europe
moi je pense que c'est important
effectivement de réfléchir à ces
questions là en ayant vraiment une
un regard sur l'avenir parce que c'est
c'est comme ça qu'on construit
finalement des désavantages sur des dons
qu'on accumule des parts de marché sur
des activités très pérenne c'est assez
certain aujourd'hui que ça va être très
compliqué de récupérer des grosses parts
de marché dans le textile en europe
c'est quelque chose qui sur des produits
de niche sur ces familles des auteurs
c'est trop tard mais je vais quand même
aller un petit peu dans
l'autoflagellation parce que cette crise
qu vida a créé des vrais bouleversements
peut être même un électrochoc en tout
cas pour beaucoup de français qui n'y
connaissait pas grand chose de découvrir
que certains de nos médicaments et
notamment le paracétamol étaient
fabriqués en chine tout notre matériel
médical pouvait être fabriqués en chine
est-ce que ça a été un tournant aussi
dans le milieu économique dont vous
faites partie est ce qu'il y a eu un
choc ou est ce qu'en fait non ça a été
juste le grand public qui a qui a
compris que voilà l'europe et la france
n'était pas au point sur la dessus oui
non pas une surprise mais c'est moi
sinon vous servir l'art à l'état vole
bien sûr oui bien sûr la pharmacie c'est
un secteur qui est extrêmement
concentrée donc le paracétamol et
produits uniquement en chine
les produits à base d'insuline sont
produits uniquement en europe les états
unis
sont très spécialisés sur les
médicaments à base de je commence à
peine mais de morphine genre de choses
c'est un secteur qui se trouve être
généré des économies d'échelle très
importante donc ça coûte beaucoup moins
cher de produire de manière très
concentrée sur les produits
pharmaceutiques et c'est pour ça que
c'est un secteur où effectivement il ya
des niveaux de concentration de la
production très important donc c'est pas
du tout une surprise
de ce point de vue là et puis plus
généralement bas évidemment c'est mon
domaine de recherche mais toutes les
questions de commerce international
c'est un domaine qui a beaucoup évolué
dans les vingt dernières années qu'on a
parce qu'il ya eu des bouleversements
majeurs la chine est entrés massivement
dans le commerce international comme ça
avait un pays comme ça qui s'ouvre
commerce international qui accumule des
taux de croissance très très important
pendant 15 ans en tirant beaucoup sa
croissance sur le commerce international
évidemment ça change tout ce qui change
tout aussi c'est encore une fois la
construction européenne marché unique ça
change tout la hull à l'union monétaire
le fonctionnement de la zone euro ça
change beaucoup de choses sur le
fonctionnement du commerce international
on a eu aussi notre révolution c'est ce
qu'on appelle la fragmentation des
chaînes de valeur c'est à dire le fait
qu'aujourd'hui on consomme produits les
biens de consommation finale beaucoup
plus qu'avant sous forme de chaînes de
production avec des étapes qui sont
fragmentés qui sont produites dans
différents pays on a beaucoup
internationalisé les chaînes de
production donc tous ces phénomènes
c'est des choses qui ont beaucoup changé
dans les vingt dernières années et qui
ont amené tous les économistes et ceux
qui travaillent sur ces questions là en
particulier à revoir finalement un peu
leur l'heure ça change évidemment la
vision qu'on a une commerce
international donc c'est vrai que c'est
un peu
intéressant je ne sais pas comment le
dire que à l'occasion de cette crise où
finalement le commerce international n'a
pas trop mal marché c'est assez étonnant
d'ailleurs parce que pendant la crise on
était quand même dans des économies qui
ne produisait plus en france on
produisait plus le commerce
international
évidemment s'est contractée de manière
massive mais on a continué à échanger
les individus ne pouvait plus voyager le
transport d'individus à l'échelle
internationale et est quasiment à
l'arrêt on a continué à livrer des
masques
c'est pour ça que le problème des
masques qui a été très caractéristique a
été finalement résolu assez vite c'est
pas parce qu'on s'est mis à produire un
petit peu de masques en france c'est
très bien mais c'est parce que
massivement on a réussi à s'assurer des
approvisionnements en chine et que ses
approvisionnements sont arrivés ça a été
transportée donc c'est c'est finalement
assez paradoxal que enfin évidemment à
la crise a marqué tout le monde s'est tu
les laisses qui s'est passé est très
choquant psychologiquement mais c'est
assez étonnant que le les questions de
commerce international et autant
focalisé l'attention alors que
finalement la plupart des choses dont on
discute qui sont des problèmes
importants liés au commerce
international sont des choses qui
étaient pré existante à la crise et moi
je pense pas que la crise est beaucoup
changé mon opinion sur ce qu'il faut
faire
en termes de politique économique mais
justement est-ce que les lignes doivent
un peu bougé ce que c'est un
enseignement qu'on doit tirer de cette
crise par exemple cessé de fabriquer que
le paracétamol en chine pour ne prendre
que cet exemple qui a frappé les esprits
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il faut
mettre un terme à ce monopole et
peut-être pour le court relocaliser la
fabrication de ce type de médicaments
chez nous ou pas à ça c'est une question
qui finalement relève pas tellement de
l'économie c'est à dire que les débats
qu'on a eue sur ces questions et à mal
notamment c'est la question de ce qu'on
peut appeler la souveraineté
stratégiques c'est-à-dire qu'on peut
dire sur certains biens
c'est important d'être capable de
produire domestiquement vous opteriez
séjour la défense pourquoi pas 10
le paracétamol est un bien qu'ils aient
suffisamment stratégique est important
pour que on ait intérêt à s'assurer une
production locale
la difficulté dans ces questions là
c'est que quand on commence à réfléchir
de cette manière c'est très facile de
considérer qu'il ya énormément de bien
qui sont stratégiques parce que
finalement il ya beaucoup de choses dont
on a besoin pour vivre au quotidien ses
cris il avait d'ailleurs très rapidement
on a besoin de dire voilà il ya
l'agroalimentaire cette stratégique la
pharmacie c'est stratégique certains
biens de capital qui sont stratégiques
le don qu'il ya énormément de choses qui
peuvent 2010 traduit de l'alimentation
et sert à ça c'est un premier point donc
très rapidement finalement on se met à
vouloir produire chez vous produire
domestiquement et donc ça a un coût il
faut le rappeler c'est un coup très
important ce qu'on produit ce qu'on va
relocaliser pour des raisons
stratégiques va être produit un coût
plus élevé en france il ya un deuxième
problème c'est que sur un certain nombre
de biens c'est difficile de relocaliser
fin si on veut vraiment une indépendance
stratégique
il faut relocaliser toute la chaîne de
production et comme je vous l'aï dit
tout à l'heure la chaîne de production
elle est fragmentée donc il suffit pas
dire la dernière étape je la relocaliser
en france parce que si vous n'avez pas
les intrants pour produire en france
vous n'avez pas d'indépendance stratégie
qui avait un petit exemple rigolo enfin
je peux c'est rigolo mais il ya eu cette
question ces tensions un peu entre les
etats-unis et le canada pendant la crise
parce que les états unis voulaient plus
exporter les masques ffp2 au canada et
le canada dit d'accord mais c'est nous
qui produisons les filtres qui sont dans
les masques et ça c'est un c'est une
anecdote je sais même pas si elle a
circulé je ne sais même pas si c'est
vérifié mais c'est très probable parce
qu'aujourd'hui la plupart des choses
qu'on achète sont des biens qui ont une
nationalité très difficile à définir la
nationalité d'un bien c'est un gros
problème statistiques de définir ce
qu'est la nationalité d'un bien parce
qu'aujourd'hui on produit des biens avec
un de morceaux qui sont produits dans
plein d'endroits donc si vous voulez
aujourd'hui être indépendant
stratégiquement sur la production j'ai
pas moins d'un avion c des centaines
d'entreprises qu'il faut relocaliser en
france et donc ça c'est très compliqué
et le dernier point c'est que ya une
alternative donc qui n'existe pas sur
tous les biens etc
mais l'alternative c'est de faire des
stocks stratégiques peut aussi se
couvrir contre des risques de
d'approvisionnement sur certains biens
en ayant des stocks stratégiques qui
sont plus importants on l'a vu le
problème c'est que définir quel est le
niveau du stock stratégique nécessaire
c'est très compliqué parce qu'il faut
anticiper quelle sera la prochaine crise
donc aujourd'hui on va je pense que là
on sort de la crise va y avoir des
masques partout il n'y a pas de problème
des respirateurs et c est ce que la
prochaine pandémie impliquera des
maladies respiratoires j'en ai aucune
idée peut-être qu'il ya des médecins qui
sont capables de dire ça des spins des
scientifiques mais voilà c'est très
difficile de deux ex ante et avant de
dire quelles seront les stocks
stratégiques dont on aura besoin dans
l'occurrence d'une crise mais ça c'est
quelque chose c'est l'analyse du risque
des risques extrêmes comme on peut
qualifier ces risques en très petite
probabilité
s'il ya des gens qui font ça c'est un
travail c'est un métier et c'est plus
l'heure finalement ce je pense que c'est
plus leur expertise à eux qu'il faut
mobiliser plutôt que celle récoltée
d'économistes et vient il ya un autre
sujet c'est que si on parle
d'indépendance stratégique on parle de
l'indépendance stratégique française ou
européenne parce que au sein même de
l'europe on se fait pas de cadeaux non
je pense que pas du tout les mêmes
acquis sociaux les mêmes politiques de
travail les mêmes c'est compliqué disons
que si on parle d'indépendance
stratégique moi ça me semble difficile
d'en parler au niveau national je pense
que nous nous sommes fixés au niveau
européen
chivu qu'il faut raisonner et dans ce
cas là en plus c'est plus facile parce
qu'il faut quand même bien voir que la
plupart des choses qu'on importe
aujourd'hui sont importés d'europe c'est
plus que 60% du commerce extérieur de la
france se fait uniquement à l'intérieur
de l'europe
donc on se focalise beaucoup sur des
biens parce que c'est vrai que c'est
frappant il ya certains biens très
spécifiques qui sont exportés
massivement de pays asiatiques des
etats-unis etc
mais c'est une très petite proportion de
ce qu'on consomme la plupart des choses
qu'on importe sont produites en europe
et sont produites aussi très largement
dans des chaînes de valeurs qui sont
très européenne ont produit c'est c'est
bien dans des chaînes de valeur
fragmenté l'europe se caractérise par un
niveau de régionalisme sur ses chaînes
de valeur qui est plus important que
dans le reste du monde si on compare par
exemple avec les états unis le japon et
cetera le marché unique finalement et le
fait de s'intégrer entre des pays très
avancés technologiquement et des pays
avec des niveaux de salaires qui sont
plus faibles a permis aussi de
développer des chaînes de valeur à
l'échelle régionale qui sont très
intégrés donc ça veut pas dire qu'on n'a
pas des dépendances forte sur certains
biens particuliers on a des dépendances
très importante vis-à-vis d'eux reste du
monde en dehors de l'europe
mais le gros de ce qu'on fait c'est à
l'échelle européenne donc en termes de
souveraineté stratégique
je pense que la bonne échelle c'est
vraiment l'échelle européenne mais c'est
intéressant de votre question parce que
finalement on a parlé beaucoup de
souveraineté stratégique mais le
problème majeur qu'on essaye de traiter
c'est celui de l'emploi est le problème
de l'emploi c'est un emploi un problème
qui est très différent qui n'a
absolument rien à voir avec le
paracétamol ou les masques c'est un
problème qui est lié en partie à un
manque de compétitivité de l'économie
française vis-à-vis de ses partenaires
européens inquiets problème et fort non
en termes de compétitivité la france
depuis quelques temps bah c'est un
problème qui est identifiée depuis
longtemps de nouveau ses bras une
nouveauté qu'on réalise avec la crise on
sait qu'il ya eu
détérioration de nos parts de marché à
l'international qui est plus importante
que dans d'autres pays européens
on a eu un niveau de baisse de l'emploi
manufacturier qui est assez important
c'est pas le plus important en europe
mais qui est assez important en europe
on a donc des déficits commerciaux sur
la balance des biens qui sont accumulés
donc il ya le diagnostic il a été fait
il ya longtemps je pense qu'il ya eu une
série de mesures qui ont essayé de
contrer ce problème là
la difficulté c'est qu'on n'a pas trouvé
de solution miracle pour l'instant donc
c'est vrai que ça reste un problème
important mais je pense que c'est très
important d'insister sur le fait que
c'est un problème qui finalement
concerne très peu leurs rapports de la
france avec la chine l'asie etc
c'est vraiment un très un problème qui a
une dimension européenne très très forte
et notamment vis-à-vis de l'allemagne un
déficit commercial vis-à-vis de
l'allemagne qui est très important et
qui effectivement contribue à notre
déficit commercial sur la balance des
biens merci merci j'avais une légende
avoir été clair nous avoir expliqué tous
et tous ces sujets je rappelle que vous
êtes économiste professeur à l'école
polytechnique et lauréate du prix du
meilleur jeune économiste 2020 merci
infiniment d'avoir accepté cet entretien
ce soir sur public sénat